sorry what do they manage to find and
pull from the ocean so far Betty
rescuers are trying to find and pull as
many bodies as possible local media
they're saying that around 40 bodies
have been recovered as dusk fell from
the sea off the coast of Borneo
Indonesian officials say they have
discovered objects that appear to be
parts of the plane local media reports
seeing an evacuation slide a box a life
jacket and other items but so far the
black box has not been found the crash
site is in an area around pine column
Boone about a thousand kilometers
southeast of Singapore and 10 kilometers
from the planes last known coordinates
now flight 8501 was headed there from
Indonesia with 162 people on board water
around the crash site is shallow at 25
to 30 meters deep and authorities are
now working with divers to try to find
the data recorders but officials there
say rough sea is hampering the recovery
process Betty and I know as you're
talking cheri the Indonesian president
Joko Widodo he is holding a press
conference right now after this
confirmation of bodies that have been
pulled and debris that's been found in
the ocean as you just mentioned so he is
right now as we speak talking about this
discovery this grim discovery and sherry
I imagine that one of the main questions
to him will be what caused this flight
to go down do we have any more clues on
that at this point out we don't have any
new information as to the possible cause
of the crash buddy so far we only know
that weather could have been a factor
the plane disappeared operators after
the pilot requested a higher altitude
because of stormy clouds in the flight
path but this is pretty normal procedure
a former pilot for British Airways
telling us that the weather itself
should not have caused what apparently
is a catastrophic accident so finding
the voice and data recorders will be
keen discovering why the airbus a321
down the boxes store of course a [ __ ]
communication sounds from the front of
the plane as well as key data points
that will help recreate the last moments
of the flight buddy sherry we're still
looking at this live feed of Joko Widodo
he I know he flew to Surabaya today he's
less than a year into his presidency how
much do we have any sense of how how
much of how good of a job he's done and
handling this so far well right now
they're trying to put everything in
perspective to try to get all the bodies
that they have found out of the water
first right now Indonesia is leading the
operations and you mentioned that Joker
with all the other present is heading to
survive well that's where they will get
the bodies that they retrieved from the
one from the water in order to identify
them but they are getting a lot of help
from other countries around Malaysia
Australia South Korea jumping in there
contributing ships planes authorities
had widen the search area across the
Java Sea as Chinese and also US military
ships headed to the region and now
officials there in Surabaya hopefully
they will give an update that's what
they're saying at this point that they
will give an update on the recovery
process tomorrow morning